tupé comencé a roble con tu bebé
hola bienvenidos una vez más a esta
emisión de canadá en las américas café
el programa que cada semana le
proponemos aquí desde el servicio en
español de radio canadá internacional
hoy estamos aquí en el estudio
nuevamente una versión concentrada del
equipo en español pero con una formación
distinta a la que presentamos en las
últimas dos semanas en este caso está
aquí rufo valencia como ésta rufo muy
bien que te condensada como un café
expresso
pero poderoso con un sabor a lima que
puede despertar a alma dormido esperemos
que así sea esperemos que sí sea bueno y
tenemos aquí vuelto de sus exóticas
vacaciones a leonardo gimeno en el este
de la isla de montreal 6 asik son
exóticos y pronunciándose así
absolutamente esto bien todo bien todo
bien muy bien mi nombre es luis laborda
y hoy tenemos también aquí con nosotros
en el estudio a un invitado para
bloggers infeld a quien conocimos
hace muy poco en realidad y qué números
24 horas
- 24 horas y mirar la audiencia y
personal gratamente altamente porque
porque tiene algo que hace falta en la
cultura por lo menos argentina voy a
esta para la ciudad
eres un argentino oriundo de tucumán
exactamente que se encuentra aquí en
canadá desde hace ya algunos años desde
el año 2007 y con él en unos instantes
más vamos a hablar y nos va a contar un
poco su un poco mucho
su periplo pero antes de lanzarnos de
lleno con el programa como hacemos
siempre vamos a presentar la música que
a la que pueden acceder que sigan esta
emisión a través de nuestro sitio en
internet que es www r6 net punto sea
barra y ese descenso del año que nos
sigan a través del sitio en internet
podrán escuchar afloran gona con un tema
que se titula app qishan es un músico de
origen nativo
que forma parte de un dúo que se llamó
casting sin nada claro con mucho éxito
los cámbulos y también me encantaría que
repetir en el nombre del tema no existe
en internet también se llama les vamos a
escuchar mejor dicho al y la sal
gilder que es una cantante de origen
tiene que también es otra de las
familias indígenas que habitan en este
país o familias tribus grupos como
ustedes quieran denominar de ella vamos
a escuchar un tema que se titula en
inglés for this land o por esta tierra y
por último la tercera invitada aunque no
necesariamente en este orden van a estar
los temas que a susan aglukkaq que es
una artista de origen hindú y que nos va
a presentar o no va a combinar hoy con
uno de sus temas más exitosos que es o
sea que en su momento llegó al puesto
número uno de los charters o de las
listas
de género folk si no me equivoco o canto
y no estoy seguro en este momento de las
artistas que ha renovado justamente la
música indígena de los inuit que
tradicionalmente es concebida como canto
de garganta si he podido combinar con
música electrónica con nuestros ritmos
señor se la reconoce precisamente por
haber funcionado bastante bien para
aquellos a quienes les gusta ese tipo de
música la música tradicional indígena
canadiense con el pop el folk la música
con dolor también ajá york - y claver
cantaba aquí en el área son ahora van de
vez en cuando hace años así que siempre
el bulevar zonal es como una especie de
cuna de muchas de muchos de estos
artistas bueno hablamos de nuestra
página en internet www rc y net punto o
sea pero no tenemos que olvidar que hay
otras vías de comunicación entre otras
facebook live y aprovechamos para
saludar a todos los que nos están
siguiendo a través de facebook live en
esta emisión o transmisión
vivo y recuerden también que nos pueden
seguir a través de nuestro canal en
youtube donde contarán con la emisión
tal cual se las presentamos en este
momento si la música sin la música ese
es un problema esto es bueno pero tiene
que ver con los derechos de facebook
tanto tanto facebook como youtube no
permiten
por una cuestión no pueden delimitar
geográficamente un vivo de estas
características entonces cuando hay
música cortan la transmisión para evitar
e incurrir en cuestiones legales por
donde pueda pasarse la música o no es
por eso que solamente quienes nos siguen
a través de nuestro sitio internet
contarán con el privilegio exacto desde
ya grande de la música me gustaría saber
el nombre del tema primero por favor
residencia pero mando después por correo
electrónico que gracias 6 es pero
decíamos que tenemos un invitado para
bloggers shenfeld gerstenfeld
a quien conocimos ayer en horas del
mediodía muy cerca de aquí de radio
canadá internacional porque pablo en
este momento se dedica a la actividad de
gastronómica tiene un local en el que se
sirven platos típicos argentinos no sé
si excluyentemente creo que también
había una comida por el momento no hay
solo argentina solamente argentinos y en
pleno centro de montreal en la avenida
en la calle sant catering aquí muy cerca
de radio canadá internacional pero pablo
tú llegaste me decías hoy a canadá en el
año 2007 que se trajo por aquí
bueno ya es como canadá cuando será
bastante chico la familia en toronto
bueno siempre sentí que tenía que
conocer un poco el mundo que yo hablaba
era francés desde chico inglés también y
muy bien siempre me había gustado mucho
y viene bueno para ver qué onda
obviamente también había muchas cosas de
la cultura de argentina
que no me gustaban que queríamos vivir
bastante mal el tema el 2001 yo viví en
buenos aires y no la pasé bien entonces
decidí ir a probar suerte a ver qué onda
y no me equivoqué creo que no estás
arrepentido el camino no estoy
arrepentido cuando hablas del 2001 vamos
a aclarar al público porque no todo el
mundo conoce el tema que estamos
hablando de la crisis financiera que
afectó a la argentina hacia fines del
2001 que provocó una debacle cuyas
consecuencias también vinieron por las
del tiempo yo trabajaba en esa época en
buenos aires para un banco muy
importante que estaba a una cuadra de
plaza de mayo donde se desencadenó todo
y la verdad que la pasé muy mal
además bueno muchas cosas de la cultura
de argentina que nunca me habían gustado
bueno yo creo que ahora la distancia
también de una bien puedo ver la
realidad de otra forma creo
en ese momento veía quizás todo lo malo
de mi país y no podía y daba por sentado
un montón de cosas que hoy en día me di
cuenta que son muy importantes
y bueno que me hicieron recapacitar un
montón digamos el tema de dejar el país
de uno no es nada fácil
y uno gana y pierde muchísimo y bueno
creo que a esta altura yo estoy acá
estoy contento pero bueno hay muchas
cosas obviamente a uno le pesan claro y
vos decías que en ese momento trabajaba
en buenos aires pero sos de la provincia
de tucumán es solamente en el centro
norte de argentina porque se dio ese
cambio esa primera inmigración de
tucumán a buenos aires básicamente
porque en argentina las cosas están
hechas para que la gente se vaya de las
provincias y así uno quiere tener un
buen trabajo se tiene que ir
su estudiante cumaná en la universidad
pública que es un excelente universidad
pero bueno cuando no se recibe se da
cuenta que las grandes empresas no están
en el interior y que uno se tiene que ir
eso le pasa a mucha gente así que bueno
me fui a buenos aires me gusta a mí me
gustan mucho buenos aires igualmente me
doy cuenta que uno para poder vivir más
o menos bien tiene que trabajar quizá el
triple de lo que uno trabaja acá para
poder llegar a comprarse no sé pantalón
cualquier cosa en una cosa bastante
complicada y ahora lo veo más todavía y
siempre y cuando tenga la posibilidad de
tener esos exámenes todos otros trabajos
que le permitan tres trabajos con la
cantidad esto para poderse comprar un
pantalón porque uno en realidad lo que
compran es en estos países no es un
pantalón sino que no compre el pantalón
que además lo pone en la sociedad en el
lugar que uno quiere estar porque no hay
necesidad de comprarse unos levi's
digamos en argentina uno lo hace porque
el argentino y en general en
latinoamérica se viste
de mostrar a qué grupo pertenece no se
va a ir a comprar el pantalón barato del
11 por ejemplo
algunos nombres es justamente algo que
me parece
relevante en lo que nos indica sea pablo
es justamente las cosas que no te
gustaban y las cosas que nos da cuenta
fuera del país algo que me di cuenta por
ejemplo desde saliendo del país fue por
ejemplo que un paseo por las calles de
la paz por ejemplo está la calle
yanacocha ayacucho socabaya tumusla
importado en la esquinas hay plazas a
este libertador a este general y uno se
da cuenta que de pronto la ciudad entera
es un monumento a los campos de batalla
la guerra la violencia y es algo que me
impresiona porque aquí tú encuentras
calles en que está ahí plazas para un
pro músico o sea el peso de la historia
es algo que y como y como la historia es
construida y cómo uno va asimilando esos
puntos de referencia históricos para
luego identificarse a partir de ellos no
es tan imposible la propia construcción
de lo que será hombre por ejemplo en
américa latina que de alguna forma
también tienen su relación con todo eso
con toda esa es ese paisaje urbano
y si no soy de esta ciudad o no y si lo
soy
cuáles son mis puntos de adición que
cuatro el punto de referencia
y eso me di cuenta que quiero que no te
gustaba que lo que es lo que no no
cuadraba con tu espíritu yo también
considero aparte de eso considero que en
latinoamérica el racismo es muy alto
muy grande cuando recién hablaba de las
calles de las ciudades
siempre en las ciudades hay los centros
de compras están divididos según el tipo
de gente
digamos el más claro sería salta en
papel salteño y salta hay dos peatonales
una peatonal digamos que la gente viene
y el resto que vendría a ser más para la
gente más humilde en tucumán es
exactamente lo mismo en buenos aires lo
mismo
me parece que esa división social es
demasiado fuerte
y a mí nunca me gustó
eso nunca me gustó en nosotros y en
ellos
nunca me gustó quizás viniendo acá me di
cuenta aún más fuerte de hasta qué punto
eso existe y creo que a qué punto eso es
lo que está degradando américa latina
también es esa cuestión esa lucha entre
grupos que se odian y que históricamente
se odiaron porque están llegando a un
punto muy grave y muy fuertemente lo que
está pasando y yo viniendo de tucumán
creo que además se nota mucho se nota
demasiado que en el norte de llama la
sociedad es mucho más tradicional en el
cual unas pocas familias que nosotros
llamamos los chicos manejan
absolutamente todo pero todo y están
acostumbradas que todo el resto de las
personas trabajen por nada claro
entonces bueno hasta qué punto eso y si
va a mantener de esa forma es difícil
decirlo estoy totalmente acuerdo yo soy
de buenos aires y vivir prácticamente
toda mi vida allí y contrariamente a la
opinión que parece tener mucha gente tan
argentina como fuera del país y en el
caso mío que tuviera suerte de poder
recorrer bastante la argentina aunque
también es cierto que me quedan muchos
rincones del país que aún no conozco y
que espero conocer algún día me parece
que en el interior del país esos
contrastes de los que estábamos hablando
son mucho más claros y se dan de manera
mucho más fuerte que en buenos aires
donde tal vez la circulación de gente
hace que la mixtura si es que existe sea
un poco más visible que en lugares por
ejemplo muy tradicionales como es el
norte argentino donde la división de la
que hemos hablado recién es
absolutamente clara pero para no
quedarse en lo negativo porque también
esa es una tendencia nuestra que es lo
positivo que el récord que rescatar de
argentina o de los lugares en los que te
va a tocado vivirla
creo que hice la paz con tucumán a horas
mucho tiempo hice la paz la gente la
gente la amistad el sentido de la
familia de la amistad es lo que 1 1 al 5
cuando los chicos en los países del
norte son fríos y uno no lo entiende
es bueno cuando uno vive acá te das
cuenta que es verdad o sea no sólo
tenemos un sentido de la amistad que no
existe acá no existe
que si yo comenzaba a trabajar en un
lugar y el poco tiempo
hacemos un asado un fútbol todo el mundo
acá acá unos trabaja años con alguien
que no saben quién es no hay grupos de
amigos grandes es más yo salí a comer
con él ayer por primera vez en el vive
latino tenemos una forma de
relacionarnos que es hermosa sí que es
una característica muy típica de américa
latina porque hablando con gente que
vive en otras actitudes no solamente
aquí en canadá la gente que vive en
europa en otras regiones del planeta
esa relación de amistad esa esa
posibilidad de conectarse de manera muy
muy rápida con el otro no se encuentran
otros y quizá en españa yo lo sentí
bastante también como que gente fácil
somos fáciles de hacer los amigos y la
verdad es que eso se extrañan mucho la
familia también el sentido de familia
que tenemos nosotros ahora él es tú al
llegar acá has tenido varios as y varios
varios caminos varias vidas
profesionales puedes contarnos cuál fue
tu periplo profesional sí bueno yo
estudié en tucumán estudié
administración de empresas una
orientación en sistemas de información
entonces toda la experiencia que había
tenido hasta en buenos aires tenía que
ver con eso - en un momento que había
alargado todo y me había decidido a
escribir y actuar en teatro bueno
también ese cambio y cuando me vine para
acá no sabía bien que lo que quería
hacer pero bueno yo pretendía cambiar
completamente de nuevo porque no estaba
del todo conforme con la parte esa más
de oficina pero bueno a las dos semanas
de haber llegado me ofrecieron un muy
buen puesto trabajando en finanzas en un
hospital
y bueno dije que sí y estuve dos años
muy a pesar mío porque no me gustaba y
de ahí me ofrecieron trabajar en una
nueva empresa en un startup que hacía en
ese momento había pocos celulares
digamos pero lo que nosotros hacíamos
era captábamos los datos de los
celulares del informe digamos de lo que
era el 3g de esa época después de salir
del té captamos todo esos datos y si
podíamos leer esos datos y dábamos
información sobre lo que las personas
digamos buscaban o qué era lo que son
los tipos de productos que ellos querían
el famoso estilo todo lo que uno hace
todo se mira todo en esa época lo único
que no se podía mirar me acuerdo era
blackberry
y que después les dieron con una caña
blackberry porque nadie lo podía ver
porque él y los gobierno podían exceder
pero eso lo podemos ver todo todo
entonces hacíamos recomendaciones que
hacemos y nosotros tenemos básicamente
no uses nada no es teléfono ni nada
podemos acceder s hacíamos informes
sobre todo los mejores los mejores
clientes no estaban en asia y entonces
claro te ofrecían según lo que buscabas
el tipo de producto que yo activa iban
ofreciendo y ahí estuve dos años que
estuvo muy bueno porque me hizo viajar
por todo el mundo fue un muy buen auguró
y después entré a otra empresa que lo
que hacíamos también era veíamos todos
los datos de utilización de twitter y
facebook de la gente y eso en algún
momento te llevó a estar conectado de
alguna manera con el canal exacto ahora
vamos a seguir hablando en unos
instantes contigo nos a contar esa parte
de tu experiencia laboral que por lo
visto es más que variada
[Música]
i
más
[Música]
bueno seguimos entonces nuestro diálogo
con pablo gerstenfeld que nos está
contando su derrotero laboral tanto en
su argentina natal como aquí en canadá y
cómo fue que llegaste a conectarte con
radio canadá
vamos a aclarar que esa relación ya
terminó tu presencia aquí no tiene nada
que ver con esa relación laboral que ver
bueno entonces íbamos teníamos otra para
una empresa que accedemos a los datos de
facebook y twitter entonces hacíamos un
ranking del programa de televisión según
la cantidad que se hablaba digamos en
todo lo que sea
red social media digamos exacto
entonces mediamos eso y eso nos hizo
trabajar acá con radio canadá y con toda
la competencia también y cómo fue que
decidiste más tarde cambiar una vez más
y adentrarte en este mundo de la
gastronomía que no sé si conocía o no
conocía para nada es decir que fue toda
una aventura y uno de diego asumido que
en américa mentes y bueno no estaba
contento con con trabajar en una oficina
sentía que quería hacer otra cosa
por otro lado digamos en muchos años
viene trabajando en tecnología
y sentía que iban a cierta edad hasta
cuanto digamos o por estar a la nueva
tecnología ya empezaban a aparecer
nuevas cosas y yo ya la verdad que no me
interesaba y la gente yo me doy cuenta
que lo que son mucho más jóvenes vienen
con mucho más conocimiento
así que empecé a pensar y siempre lo
tuve en la cabeza
digamos que bueno primero la empanada
tucumán en un panal excelente estoy
convencido doy fe
he comido la santiagueña que son las
empanadas las piernas abiertas y las
salteñas también pero la tucumana es
para nosotros y entonces yo decía bueno
porque el taco es tan popular y no la
empanada bueno hay que hacerle justicia
a la empanada igual tengo mi respuesta
de por qué el taco es tan popular y no
la empanada no hay por qué por el
trabajo que demandan la empanada
tiene tanto trabajo manual por detrás
que le hacen mucho menos rentable no se
necesita mucho en general las comidas
digamos del norte las comidas de
latinoamérica en general están basadas
en mano de obra porque en los países
digamos nosotros la mano de obra es
barata y los productos son caros cuando
hablamos de maniobra en el aspecto
culinario tenemos es decir estamos
hablando de preparación
para armar una unidad en una persona
arreglando choclo no sé cuánto tiempo si
en vez de ahí para armar una empanada de
carne tucumana de gente una persona que
te corte la carne en pedacitos
chiquititos la preparación tiene que
estar al menos 24 horas en el heladera
para que esté fría y se pueda preparar
no es simple una logística bastante
complicada que sea exacto el otro mucho
más fácil el taco ya directamente está
todo y se lo arma y directamente la
empanada la humita el arroyo de
matahambre llámale lo que quiera el
locro todo demanda mucho tiempo es muy
trabajoso es más cuando yo invito a
comer asados algunos de ustedes han
tenido la posibilidad comer asados una
memoria la suerte de la fortuna gracias
el asado es paciencia hay que estar una
hora y media sentado al lado del fuego y
aquí hacen esos son los resultados es
decir estamos aquí hablando con uno de
hoy fue de eso con uno de los mejores
asadores que se pueda encontrar en la
isla de montreal
no sé si uno de los mejores pero el
grupo que tengo con mis amigos en
montreal es el asado de lejos el mejor
es perfecto y como fue entonces que te
decidiste a encarar es de este trabajo
tan tan complicado de la economía
argentina siendo que no tenía
experiencia previa lo primero que yo
creía mucho en el producto entonces lo
que hice me fui a tucumán y le pagué a
una persona
una persona un profesional de la
empanada para que me enseñe todo lo que
sabía dos veces
y después cuando volví estuve durante un
año en mi casa siendo yo la empanada con
lo que yo encontré que había acá
taponándolo adaptándola claro porque no
se consigue exactamente los mismos
productos cuando uno dice hacer una
cómoda charla vamos a tener con
compartan mientras comíamos charlábamos
de comida como somos así de glotones
hablábamos con respecto a la diferencia
entre las pizzas de argentina que acá
tenemos un consumidor y amante de la
pizza argentina con respecto a la pizza
canadiense el queso a la manera de
preparar la masa el tiempo de cocción el
tipo de masa son todos cambios la pizza
en realidad básicamente es la misma pero
los condimentos yo las de manera y los
ingredientes son diferentes hay que
tratar de que eso sea parecido para
tener bueno
el objetivo es ese no va a ser lo más
parecido posible yo yo hay cosas que
pude encontrar acá y cosas que las
traigo muchas de las especias que se
usan yo las traigo de argentina
para eso digamos porque si quiero lograr
un buen resultado yo no encontré acá
digamos y sobre todo dos especias cuales
el pimentón por ejemplo kaká y páprika
pero la páprika testing y todo sería
igual no sé cuál sea yo traigo pimentón
y el ají molido que el ají molido se usa
en argentina que no es picante es muy
poquito picante bastante suave pero
tiene mucho sabor filón esos dos yo los
traigo de allá y además aunque consigas
alguna variedad que se podría llegar a
utilizar los gustos varían de unas veces
otras no es exactamente lo mismo
entonces cuando se trata de cocina
típica de algún lugar si no se logra ese
gusto que no está buscando el plato se
degeneran otra otra cosa que lo que uno
quiere producir exactamente
[Música]
pues aquí tenemos justamente a nuestros
amigos a palabra martínez y esta mira
observando el programa paloma cómo está
su salud que nosotros así que también
está daniel camporini quién estás pues
está bastante elocuente
como tenemos tiempo uno de nuestros
compañeros civiles del otro lado del
micrófono sí sí está bien también
estamos con javier gonzález nungaray que
también nos está siguiendo por facebook
live así que un saludo a nuestros amigos
los dos ellos
leonardo algún mensaje no son los mismos
en realidad está mirando tenemos luis
balderas no sé si lo nombra este luis
valdez también
están todos conectados con nuestro
facebook live participando en las redes
en las redes sociales así que ellos
tienen preguntas comentarios pues
adelante yo aprovecho entonces para dar
acuse de recibo a quienes nos envían
mensajes sobre sobre todo sobre las
cuestiones laborales y de inmigración en
este caso sandra margarita mero cordero
césar leonardo ulises lópez rosas
francisco cabrera y liana víctor gas y
la sitúa maría en lópez rivera seseña
rodríguez miranda arteaga néstor mejía
gonzález x son villegas y maría
magdalena du en todos ellos nos han
hecho llegar consultas sobre el tema
laboral y la inmigración y como los
mismos dicho en maneras en varias
ocasiones en más de una oportunidad en
todo caso que esas respuestas están en
los sitios de internet que ustedes
pueden consultar
fácilmente lanzarte a un negocio de
comidas típicas en este caso de comidas
tradicionales argentinas con la gran
variedad de cocinas que presenta
montreal no te produjo un miedo en el
inicio
yo
sé que la gente montreal le gusta la
novedad le gusta probar cosas nuevas
yo además les di un pequeño twist
digamos al producto yo le creo si yo le
agregue colores a la masa
qué quiere decir esto una empanada
violeta tenemos una empanada negra
tenemos una empanada verde tenemos una
empanada roja hacemos la empanada
amarilla
porque porque se me había ocurrido que
porque a los tallarines se le puede
poner colores y no a la masa de la
empanada así que me la pasé probando
todos con cosas naturales digamos así es
que a la amarilla a la verde le puse
espinacas y quedó perfecta a la amarilla
le puse
de cúrcuma y pimiento amarillo
y quedó muy bien a la roja le puse
pimiento rojo y así fui probando y quedó
muy bien y llamativa muy bonita a la
oferta y la gente te manda esos platos
por su color eso hace que la gente le
llame la atención si eso sí me parece
que hace una gran diferencia al plato
los menos aburridos son las empanadas
que viste montreal donde las empanadas y
en sus camisetas de color no se los
distingue por su por su vestimenta y si
se distinguen por sí vivir las verdes y
hay muchas que hay que probar así que
estaremos ahí por ejemplo de pescado que
veía que había creado que no sé si es
hace parte del repertorio tradicional de
las empanadas tucumanas tenemos de
pescado no creo que no sea la empanada
de pescado es una empanada típica en la
empanada gallega que se lo usa para las
croquetas no hablen para la gallega se
la hace grande en grande es una tarta
sacarla
pero me llaman work si vamos a lo que es
tucumán tucumán tiene sólo dos empanadas
quizás tres tiene carne ni pollo listón
del mundo aunque puede llegar a
conseguir después digamos la de queso
las en tu casa no las vas a comprar
ningún lado
pero bueno si yo quería tener digamos el
lugar de empanada tiene que tener más
variedad entonces fui pensando en
diferentes opciones
obviamente menos área y empanada de todo
buenos aires y pero si vos te vas a
tucumán y le ofrece una empanada de
espinaca con roquefort y nueces como
ofrecemos nosotros la gente dice esto no
es una empanada empanada de cebolla
caramelizada con manzana
nosotros si lo hacemos si de hecho la
empanada gallega es una para mina de la
más rica
y bueno antes de proseguir nuestro
diálogo quería recordarle a quienes nos
siguen a través del sitio en internet
www brc y net punto o sea que van a
poder escuchar música de tres artistas
canadienses todos ellos con raíces
indígenas flora marc bolan lila hilda y
susan aglukkaq de esos temas musicales
están entonces en nuestra página en
internet y los podrán escuchar a partir
de primeras horas de la tarde de hoy
hora de montreal que es cuando
publicamos nuestro programa en nuestro
sitio de internet y donde permanece todo
el fin de semana hasta el lunes por la
mañana rufo valencia tiene mensajes de
poesía y además de además debes valderas
que nos escribe desde el puerto de san
antonio en chile donde seguramente haber
un excelente pescado a esta hora
entonces también está con nosotros
verónica chapman pablo arce a quienes
pues damos la bienvenida
está también francisco miranda a renato
méndez
gabriel ramírez de bi diurex ya que
siempre está con nosotros y manfred
echeverría creo que desde mexico si no
me equivoco bueno yo tengo aquí cartas
que nos han hecho llegar hace ya algún
tiempo nuestros oyentes en la mayoría de
los casos de cuba cartas que llegaron
por el tradicional correo postal de ese
que ya casi no se usa cada vez menos y
queríamos dar por lo menos acuse de
recibo de esa correspondencia entre
otros nos enviaron cartas tania espinoza
pérez que es de holguín en cuba
justina amarilla saldívar saldívar que
es de freire también en holguín y tengo
aquí otra que nos envió rafael reyes
plaza que es de en este caso santiago de
cuba también allí en la isla caribeña de
cuba todos ellos y a otras que todavía
tenemos aquí para dar cuenta de esa
correspondencia muchas gracias por
haberse tomado el tiempo de escribirnos
y como siempre esperamos sus
comunicaciones por el canal que ustedes
y efectuarlo rufo aquí el mensaje de
antonio cotejo quien injustamente
reacciona una reportaje que hicimos una
entrevista sobre divergencias entre el
gobierno de canadá y los movimientos
sociales en torno a venezuela entonces
aquí antonio cotejo dice que radio canal
y trans radio canadá internacional al
hacer ese tipo de declaraciones
demuestra una completa ignorancia de la
situación venezolana o bien una
complicidad hacia uno de los regímenes
más terribles y criminales de la
historia de nuestro país
en primer lugar ninguna guerra mediática
el país con la reserva problema del
planeta está muriendo no sólo por la
delincuencia desbordada sino por falta
de alimentos y medicinas básicas en
segundo lugar no es una guerra económica
simplemente el régimen se apoderó de
todo el aparato productivo nacional para
hacer de los venezolanos dependientes
del estado pero su incapacidad y
corrupción destruyeron todo por último
esa supuesta observación internacional
para las últimas elecciones en venezuela
estuvo compuesta por puras
naciones y países abiertamente adeptos
al régimen venezolano dice nuestro amigo
antonio cotejo quien tiene una opinión
diferente a la de la entrevistada en ese
momento y aquí en este caso tengo
otro mensaje de ligia kaman y sobre el
tema en canadá primer santuario en el
mundo para ballenas y delfines en
cautiverio y ella nos dice y qué hay del
negocio de la piel de foca que se estaba
hablando de las ballenas y delfines nos
particularmente las focas y ella nos
explica que la matanza anual de flock de
crías es cruel y feroz y que el gobierno
hace caso omiso de la opinión mundial
las especies animales no son propiedad
de nadie son patrimonio de la humanidad
es el comentario de ligia cam
[Música]
si tú
sexual
sexto
sí
bueno y antes de pasar a los temas que
hemos estado trabajando esta semana aquí
en la sección quería preguntarle a pablo
nuestro invitado desde cuándo está el
negocio que estás manejando en este
momento desde el año pasado en el mes de
marzo y que respuestas obtenido hasta
ahora esa cocina tradicional argentina
yo creo que después del sandwich de
milanesa ha sido mucho muy alta la
empanada pero esa noche en esa muy bien
muy buena muy buena respuesta tanto por
la empanada la que por ejemplo la mitad
en olla que nosotros servimos como sopa
para explicarla en un éxito increíble el
locro que lo hacemos en invierno también
es impresionante la gente como le gusta
así igual logró igual que algún logro
como dio un locro limpio no le meto ni
mondongo ni cabeza de nada ni pata de
nada pero
a la gente le encanta lo que ya y alguna
ocasión harás el loco sucio yo lo sé
pero no sé a cómo lo iban a tomar con
eso no lo que el pequeño especial para
los perros que para usar antes de que
vea el contraste la vez que escuché la
palabra logro mi primer contacto con la
palabra logro fue leyendo patoruzito
local se llama la llamaban llama mate
han preguntado por qué ese nombre y
mucha gente mucha gente no sabe lo que
es mucha gente no lo conoce y mucha
gente cree que es peruano también e
inclusive mucha gente de argentina no
conoce el para la pachamama a lo que me
llama la atención porque para nosotros
es muy conocido y como se lo explicas y
bueno pachamama digamos en que he hecho
es la madre tierra digamos
en tucumán además hay dos festivales que
son los más importantes de todos que es
el festival de la pachamama que lo hacen
en la mancha del valle y el festival de
la empanada que se hace en familia
así que bueno y te ha ocurrido de que te
pidan en habló de los clientes de que te
pidan la receta de uno de esos platos de
la unita todo el tiempo y mitad
sí claro ya mitad del locro lo que pasa
que bueno el otro es bastante complicado
porque el maíz blanco que usamos
nosotros no se consigue fácilmente yo
consiguió un lugar que me lo trae eso
sumado a las especias como tengo como
solo las traemos de afuera exactamente
es difícil más de pero bueno igual todas
las recetas digamos en internet se puede
conseguir diríamos la receta no es el
tema
por ejemplo hace un año en mi casa
hicimos un wanna be locro porque fue
wanna be no no fue logró el puro puro
digamos porque hay un montón de
justamente condimentos e ingredientes
que no se consiguen uno trata de
reemplazarlo con lo que le parece más o
menos la denuncia pero bueno eso el
gusto cambia pero uno no se siente
reconfortado al mismo tiempo porque pero
por eso mismo el truco no está en las
recetas sino en el sabor que se obtiene
en la mayor parte del proceso parte del
trabajo del que pablo venía hablando
desde hace un tiempo que me llama la
atención también
cómo cambia el nombre de la fruta y las
verduras según el lugar que tiene la
humita entonces de dónde sos vos
entonces si vienen de colombia y
venezuela entonces les digo bueno tiene
maíz auyama que es cebolla y que eso lo
llama el zapallo también algunas veces
tener que escribir un listado de nombres
de alimentos para un libro que se
utiliza actualmente en un instituto que
enseña el español canadienses a nuevo a
no hispanoparlantes y para estar seguros
de que uno no había abusado de los
nombres localistas de pase ese texto a
una colega chilena y a otra colega
peruana y era impresionante la cantidad
de nombres de frutas por ejemplo que son
se llaman de una manera en argentina y
en chile que está al lado el otro lado
de la cordillera no tienen la menor idea
de lo que uno está hablando
del zapallo es también todos los lugares
en méxico a la remolacha le dicen
betabel rarísimo claro que en el
interior de argentina le dicen bétera va
que en realidad es
algo muy similar pero no es exactamente
lo mismo que me dice tárraga betarraga y
bueno antes de despedirlo pablo les voy
a proponer le voy a proponer
específicamente a mi colega rufo
valència que le presente al público cuál
es el tema de todos los que haya estado
trabajando durante esta semana para que
accedan a él de manera prioritaria lo
que destacó para esta semana justamente
es que toronto hace algunas unas semanas
pidió al gobierno federal que se
prohíban las armas la venta de
municiones en la ciudad y también una
prohibición de las armas y esta semana
la semana comenzó con la decisión
unánime la diferencia de toronto unánime
de montreal de pedir al gobierno
canadiense la prohibición de las armas
de fuego en todo el país y justamente
uno de los portavoces de esta moción en
el consejo municipal de esta ciudad que
es la segunda ciudad de importancia en
canadá toronto la primera ciudad es que
estamos hablando de las más grandes
ciudades de canadá que concentran la
mayor cantidad de habitantes canadienses
en estos centros urbanos
y están pidiendo al gobierno canadiense
que se prohíban
definitivamente las armas de fuego
cortas y también las armas de asalto y
álex noris decía justamente que se ve
con demasiada frecuencia armas de asalto
que han sido fabricadas para matar a la
gente en manos de personas que no tienen
ninguna razón válida para poseerlas y es
obvio preguntarse para qué rayos una
persona puede analizar un arma militar
en una ciudad entonces hay este empuje
para que de una vez
que nada pueda tomar iniciativas
recordemos que el gobierno previo de los
conservadores de harper justamente ellos
tomaron el camino totalmente opuesto más
eliminaron el registro de arma y
eliminan justamente una una herramienta
de trabajo para la policía y hay que
decir que la propuesta de tanto de
toronto como de montreal de prohibir las
armas de fuego tiene el apoyo de los
policías porque ellos por ejemplo el
registro os permitirá saber si hay una
llamada de tal casa saber si es casa hay
o no hay armas y claro obviamente que es
una esta es una medida que
tiene mucha mucha oposición de parte de
minúsculos osea porcentualmente
minúsculos sectores de la sociedad
canadiense que son más bien más
influidos por el discurso de la de
estadounidenses de la posesión de armas
como bien decirse en el caso de canadá
se trata de grupos realmente
minoritarios la realidad en ese sentido
en canadá es totalmente distinta a la
presente en estados unidos donde el
lobby de las armas es realmente poderoso
y no solamente poderoso por peso
político sino por peso económico
efectivamente son que son organizaciones
son fabricantes de armas que pues ponen
plata en la mesa a los a los miembros
del congreso y pues uno puede alquilar
un congresista básicamente a partir de
esta mirada y los hay de hecho hay
parlamentarios en eeuu que son puramente
voceros de los grupos de presión ligados
a la venta de armas efectivamente
entonces es el tema y vamos a ver ahora
si el gobierno canadiense prestará
atención a este pedido no creo porque
estamos a un año y ya de esas las
elecciones
y justamente la derecha se ha hecho un
caballito de batalla del que comienza el
derecho a tener armas entonces es muy
difícil que tuvieron en tal contexto
pueda tomar una medida tan tan
importante como sería prohibir las armas
en cortas y de asalto en canadá pues muy
bien muchas gracias rojos yo por mi
parte le ofrezco a la gente que acceda a
una entrevista que realice esta semana
con laura leyva
ella es una bióloga de origen hondureño
pero que actualmente está haciendo un
doctorado en alemania y participó meses
atrás de la expedición norte pacific que
fue una expedición que se realizó en
aguas del océano pacifico para constatar
los niveles de contaminación con
productos de plástico que llegan a las
aguas de los distintos océanos en todo
el mundo
y llamaría la atención principalmente
sobre la presencia en microplásticos es
decir porciones de material plástico que
son más pequeñas que 5 milímetros y que
constituyen un riesgo como un problema
principal porque el tamaño de esas
partículas hace que los peces los
animales marinos lo confundan con el
plancton que es la base de la cadena
alimenticia marina entonces hemos visto
en los últimos meses una cantidad de
animales que aparecen con pedazos de
plástico en su organismo en su sistema
digestivo por haberlo ingerido y esta
contaminación por supuesto además a
través del consumo del agua llega
también a los seres humanos en el caso
de las mujeres por ejemplo afecta la
fertilidad
y otro tema que le llamó la atención al
aura leyva fue que uno de los lugares
más contaminados por el plástico lo
encontró nada más y nada menos que en
territorio canadiense en broken island
que es un grupo de islas ubicadas en el
oeste de canadá en columbia británica se
encontró con la concentración de
desperdicios de desechos de plástico más
grande que haya visto ella en su vida
esos desperdicios vienen en parte
arrojados por los humanos
voluntariamente en otros casos de manera
involuntaria como por ejemplo cuando
ocurrió el tsunami en japón en 2011 que
arrastraron parte de esos desechos hacia
lugares como provoquen island ustedes
tienen allí entonces esa entrevista que
pueden consultar en nuestro sitio de
internet no nos queda más tiempo gracias
a cabo son los últimos segundos de este
programa aprovechamos para saludar y
para agradecerle entonces a pablo
gerstenfeld uipba perdón gerstenfeld
pablo gerstenfeld su presencia aquí
en nuestro programa muchas gracias pablo
ya no será nuevamente por tu local que
está muy cercano a quienes les
agradecemos también la presencia de
todos los que nos siguen a través de
facebook lite les pedimos que sea
facebook live también a quienes nos
siguen por youtube y a quienes nos
siguen a través de nuestro sitio en
internet www eres y net punto se ha no
nos quedan más tiempo muchas gracias
hasta la próxima y que tengan todos un
buen fin de semana a 10 años aves